of all the actors who came of age in the
80s few seemed as destined for
superstardom as Rebecca De Mornay her
wit humanity and charisma seemed to put
her a cut above her contemporaries but
where did her career end up taking her
while she never reached superstar status
you've probably seen more of her than
you realize
De Mornay got her foot in the door of
Hollywood with a minor role in 1981 s 1
from the heart a musical romance from
director Francis Ford Coppola if you
haven't heard of it it's probably
because it hasn't held on in pop culture
like some of the directors other movies
such as The Godfather Apocalypse Now or
Jack but it was still a strong start for
De Mornay who followed up her debut with
a breakout lead role in risky business
that movie's a legit 80s classic
practically made an icon out of her
co-star fellow up-and-comer Tom Cruise
if you're totally unfamiliar risky
business is a classic coming-of-age tale
where boy meets girl except the girl is
a mysterious prostitute and the boy is
an inexperienced suburbanite the two
meet when Cruz's questionable
decision-making skills land him in
serious financial straits forcing him to
find a unique way to make a lot of money
in a short amount of time the result is
a comedy about a homegrown brothel that
somehow stays charming the movie made
Cruz an overnight superstar and Marc De
Mornay as an instant it girl but while
Cruz's star power continued to grow des
mortes new status proved a little bit
harder to hold on to
after risky business des mortes career
took off she followed her breakout film
with a supporting turn in 1983 Testament
but her stardom took a serious hit in
1985 with the poorly reviewed baseball
rom-com the sluggers wife you can't
blame her for jumping into a film
written by Neil Simon and directed by
Hal Ashby it just didn't work out
luckily De Mornay kept her footing with
a pair of solid supporting turns in 1985
the first a heartfelt drama called the
trip to bountiful found her sharing
scenes with screen legend Geraldine page
in a movie that got attention from the
Oscars the other runaway train is more
of a pulse-pounding crowd-pleaser with
the actress as a railroad employee
working to thwart two escaped convicts
that have sabotage to Train despite
having a story by akira kurosawa and
earning three Oscar nominations the
movie is now often overlooked
but it was impressive at the time and
helped keep de mornay's career chugging
right along in 1986 de Morny caught a
ride with the rock band starship
specifically she co-starred in the music
video for Sarah the song was one of the
most successful tracks of the year
climbing the charts to hit number one on
the Billboard Hot 100 De Mornay appeared
in the video for the shamelessly
schmaltzy song alongside starship singer
Mickey Thomas telling a story about a
dissolving relationship despite its
contemporary success the song doesn't
get much play anymore but at least it
hasn't become as hated as we built this
city did though the 80s started out
strong for her De Mornay spent the
second half of the decade starring in
projects that ranged from questionable
to downright abominable these movies
included and God created woman feds and
dealers but the worst one was 1987 s
mind-bogglingly bad version of Beauty
and the Beast on paper it didn't sound
so bad the movie was one of the only few
english-language adaptations of the
classic fairy tale and the first to come
up with the idea of turning it into a
musical beating Disney - the concept by
a full five years John Savage was cast
to play the beast - de mornay's beauty
but neither was served well by the
finished product the movie was
criticized for being half-hearted and
uninspired with less than stellar makeup
effects and unmemorable music the actors
deserve credit for performing the songs
themselves but it was ultimately a risk
that didn't pay off after a string of
cinematic misfires De Mornay hit the
reset button on her career the actress
kicked off the 90s with a small screen
role as a bomber pilot in HBO's
emmy-winning cold war tinged original by
dawn's early light the next year in 1991
she found herself at the top of the box
office when Ron Howard cast her in his
smash hit firefighter drama backdraft
while the mornay's role is only a
supporting one her skills on the big
screen still showed it's a performance
that must have made an impression with
her peers particularly director Curtis
Hanson who cast her as a villainous
would-be nanny in his 1992 thriller the
hand that rocks the cradle' des morning
more than delivered the goods as the
psychologically damaged character and
this time found herself the lead in a
blockbuster hit that held the number one
spot at the box office for four straight
weeks De Mornay spent the 90s coupling
her acting projects with producer
credits the work including never talk to
strangers the
winner and a table for one De Mornay
also made an appearance on the mid-90s
revival of the popular anthology series
the Outer Limits on which she earned her
one and only credit as a director her
episode the conversion premiered as the
twelfth installment of the series
telling a complex violent story
the conversion follows a man fresh out
of prison and harboring a serious grudge
against his former employers the sort of
grudge that drives him to pick up a gun
and opened fire on his old offices
Christmas party as one might expect with
the sci-fi fantasy series all is not
what it appears to be with De Mornay
playing a key role as a mysterious woman
who may or may not be pulling the
strings on the whole situation what were
you thinking about find a drink for
someone you don't even know working
behind the camera she handled the
challenging material with style and grit
delivering a violent clever character
study about mistakes and second chances
she also got to direct her old Beauty
and the Beast co-star John Savage in the
process Rebecca De Mornay x' career
continued to flourish throughout the 90s
but 1997 saw the actor take one of her
biggest risks yet when she landed the
role of Wendy Torrence in the
made-for-tv miniseries adaptation of
Stephen King's The Shining the story had
already been adapted by Stanley Kubrick
almost two decades prior with iconic
performances from Jack Nicholson and
Shelley Duvall with the original being
regarded by many as one of the best
horror movies ever made the stakes were
high for the three-part miniseries with
comparisons to the classic first
adaptation being inevitable King being
no fan of Kubrick's adaptation took on
the task of scripting the episodes
himself resulting in a four and a half
hour adaptation that's as faithful to
the novel as possible for better or
worse as for De Mornay and her on-screen
husband Steven Weber each finds a way to
make the characters their own helping
make their version of The Shining a
respectable effort that has Stephen
King's seal of approval after finding
some genuine small screen success with
the emmy-nominated adaptation of The
Shining De Mornay wasted little time
booking her next TV gig she ended up
landing on one of the greatest and
longest-running series ever produced er
de mourning made her debut in the first
episode of the series sixth season
playing Elaine Nichols a wealthy
seductress in a relationship with Noah
Wiley's
to Carter with the twist being that her
character is also the recently divorced
ex-wife of Carter's cousin was he sad
I'll be thinking of you tonight
I guess I meant it throughout DeMornay
Sark the pair faced numerous challenges
including the obvious family turmoil
their dramatic age difference and
eventually a breast cancer storyline
that sees Carter trying to be supportive
as Elaine endures a mastectomy
eventually the couple ends things with
Elaine running off to Europe to start
anew and Carter staying in Chicago to
continue saving lives though des mortes
role lasted just five episodes it
remains one of the series more memorable
guest appearances though she's had
serious successes on the small screen De
Mornay has always done her best work in
feature films a shrewd bit of casting
gave De Mornay a chance to showcase the
full range of her talents when she
played the role of an aging TV star with
a nasty streak in James Mangold's
psychological thriller identity
conceived as an Agatha Christie style
whodunit the movie is an ensemble piece
following a group of strangers stalked
by a murderer in a seedy isolated motel
at the same time the movie focuses on
the testimony of a potentially
schizophrenic death row inmate whose
mind may hold the key to the gruesome
mystery at hand needless to say there's
a lot to unpack with identity as the
film twists and turns to an unexpected
conclusion over 15 years after its
release the movie remains a uniquely
satisfying Mindbender that just so
happens to feature one of the best
performances of Rebecca De Mornay x'
career though she was blessed with
leading lady looks and acting chops to
match DeMornay has never been one to shy
away from playing compelling supporting
characters in bigger movies more often
than not she's made the most of these
minor roles bringing rich personalities
to even the most marginal of characters
of her supporting turns few were more
memorable or more brief than her role as
a vindictive divorcee in the opening
moments of 2005 s outlandish comedy
wedding crashers she's the woman who
traded barbs with Dwight Yoakam as one
half of a soon-to-be divorced couple who
are forced to remember the good times by
Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson's divorce
mediators though the scene clocks in at
just about 3 and a half minutes it
serves as a perfect tone setter for the
raucous action that follows all mostly
thanks to De Mornay you shut your mouth
when you're talking to me now more than
four decades into her career des mortes
professional life has continued to
flourish like many former it girls and
young movie icons who came up exploiting
their sex appeal De Mornay has made a
second career of sorts out of playing ma
on screen in the last 15 years alone
she's played a parental role in over a
dozen projects on screens both big and
small including turns on John from
Cincinnati American Reunion mother's day
American Venus and Hatfields and McCoys
all while playing real-life mom to two
daughters of her own of course d'amour
neighs most memorable turn as a
fictitious mother has been as Dorothy
Walker the fame-hungry woman whose
daughter is Trish Patsy Walker on
Netflix is Jessica Jones like many of
her supporting turns over the years De
Mornay brings a hefty dose of humanity
to the role helping make a complex human
being out of what might otherwise have
been a shrill patently unlikable
character taking you in was the worst
decision of my life thanks mom
as Rebecca De Mornay nears her 60th
birthday it's clear that the acclaimed
actor has no intention of slowing down
having recently completed a two-episode
arc on Fox's Lucifer and appearing in
2018 s family drama periphery as for
what lies ahead we expect to see De
Mornay reprise her role as Dorothy
Walker in the third season of Jessica
Jones
she's also slated to play a key role in
the Nick Cannon directed women's
basketball drama she ball from there the
sky seems to be the limit for the gifted
career performer one thing we know for
sure is that she seems primed to
continue playing strong intelligent
complex women on TV shows and movies for
years to come check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]